While bikinis seem like a no-brainer for a swimsuit issue,...
...other strings are also garnering great attention.
Silk - wrapped bracelets called Bhati beads by Margaret Maggard.
Well as my husband said, "There's jewelry in Sports Illustrated Swimsuit?"
These pieces, what I think the reason why they do well is because you can wear them when you're 55 years old...
...and you don't have to get into a bikini.
And, you know, you may not look like one of these girls in the magazine,...
...but you can have a little piece of that.
A yoga instructor, Maggard was crafting jewelry for friends in the basement of her Milwaukee home.
When she started to look towards selling outside her circle,...
...she ran across the 2006 swimsuit issue...
...and it proved inspirational.
And I saw the jewelry they were wearing...
...and I noticed who was making the jewelry, and I thought, "I wanna be with those guys."
As a little manufacturer, do you think that would help you or hurt you going in?
I thought it would hurt me.
I thought they want the big names.
But I thought, "It's so perfect."
So, Maggard made 12 bracelets and sent them to MJ Day.
The simple styling was a hit.
It's just something that really grabbed our attention...
...and worked really well with where we are now, with how we style.
Like, what the girls would be wearing if they were to just throw on their own jewelry.